wie viele Krisen willst du managen oder
Scholz vermutlich könnte man so die
ersten eineinhalb Jahre für Olaf Scholz
als Bundeskanzler in einem meme
zusammenfassen wir stecken noch mitten
in der corona-pandemie als Scholz sein
Amt antritt dann krieg Energieknappheit
Angst vor einem kalten Winter
hunderttausende geflüchtete Inflation
und dazu noch zwei Koalitionspartner die
sich ständig in die Haare kriegen aber
Olaf Scholz der kühle norddeutsche steht
im Sturm und scheint von all dem nicht
besonders beeindruckt zu sein wir
schauen uns in diesem Video an wie Olaf
Scholz ist schon bevor er Kanzler wurde
hinbekommen hat das scheinbar alles an
ihm abreißt auch Kritik und vor allem
schauen wir auf die Zahlen des
politbarometers und fragen wie das bei
den Wählerinnen und Wählern so ankommt
[Musik]
polytetra fluorethylen auch bekannt als
Teflon damit beschichtet man Pfannen
damit Spiegeleier nicht anbraten oder
Jacken damit der Regen daran abhält kurz
eine Antihaftbeschichtung an der nicht
kleben bleibt egal wie hartnäckig es ist
schon seit ein paar Jahren verwendet die
Presse die Metapher Teflon Scholz dann
auch für Olaf Scholz daneben scheint
auch vieles einfach abzukehren selbst
Markus Lanz gab einmal zu er habe sich
ein Olaf Scholz die Zähne ausgebissen
weil der ein Interviews immer komplett
kontrolliert oder völlig anders antworte
als erwartet oder nur ganz kurz und
spärlich super super mir sowas nicht man
nennt ihn auch den Scholz Oma matt einen
emotionslosen Roboter nüchtern bis an
die Schmerzgrenze Olaf Scholz scheint
nicht gerne öffentlich Emotionen zu
zeigen z.B als er 2011 zum Regierenden
Bürgermeister seiner Heimatstadt Hamburg
gewählt wird ich gebe zu als ich die
ersten Umfragen gehört hatte bin ich
erstmal Nebenraum gegangen
und nicht alleine darüber zu freuen
2017 organisiert er den G20-Gipfel in
Hamburg es kommt zu Ausschreitungen
ganze Stadtviertel brennen aber Scholz
beißt alle Vorwürfe eine schlechten
Krisenmanagements nüchtern zurück
jenseits von Hamburg scheint das G20
Desaster auch schnell vergessen ich
bedanke mich auch bei den Bürgern und
Bürgern unserer Stadt die nicht weniges
erdulden mussten wo einige erleben
mussten dass ihre Autos angezündet
wurden dass ihre Geschäfte zerstört
worden sind das alles darf nicht
stattfinden ist um verzeihlich und
unvertretbar nur wenige Monate später
wird er zum Bundesfinanzminister und
Vizekanzler Berufen in dieser Zeit geht
der Zahlungsdienstleister Wirecard
Pleite Scholz Ministerium steht in der
Kritik fahrlässlich gehandelt zu haben
aber auch das geht spurlos an Scholz
vorbei auch der nächste Skandal scheint
an Teflon Scholz abzupreisen zumindest
stand April 2023 es handelt sich um den
cum-ex-steuer Skandal das ist eine
komplizierte Sache kurz zusammengefasst
betrüger nutzen Aktiengeschäfte um sich
zu bereichern sie bekommen mehr Thema
Kapitalertragssteuern vom Finanzamt
zurückgezahlt obwohl sie sie nur einmal
bezahlt haben das ist
Steuerhinterziehung Steuerbetrug
befindet jedenfalls der
Bundesgerichtshof die Hamburger
warburgbank war darin verwickelt und
soll eigentlich 47 Millionen Euro ans
Hamburger Finanzamt zurückzahlen die von
Zauberhand lässt das Finanzamt diese
Forderung aber wieder fallen wir
erinnern uns damals ist Scholz noch
Hamburgs Bürgermeister und trifft sich
nachweislich mehrfach mit dem Chef
dieser Bank hat er also etwas damit zu
tun
komischerweise kann Scholz sich gar
nicht mehr an die Gespräche erinnern ob
Scholz tatsächlich politisch Einfluss
genommen hat ist bis heute nicht klar
allerdings hat es Scholz Wahl zum
Bundeskanzler kein bisschen behindert im
Gegenteil die Skandale seiner beiden
Kontrahenten scheinen die Wählerinnen
und Wähler weit mehr enttäuscht zu haben
bärburg stolpert über
Urheberrechtsverletzungen und einen
falschen Lebenslauf oder zumindest
falsche Angaben und Laschet lacht im
Aartal
Teflon Scholz wird als beliebtester
SPD-Politiker scheinbar weitgehend
unbeschadet der 9 Bundeskanzler der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland laut ZDF
Politbarometer der Forschungsgruppe
Wahlen bei Olaf Scholz nie beliebter als
kurz nach der Bundestagswahl am 1
Oktober 2021 erntet er seinen
persönlichen Bestwert von 2,2 auf einer
Bewertungsskala von -5 er ist zu diesem
Zeitpunkt der beliebteste Politiker
überhaupt nach Angela Merkel drei
Viertel der Befragten wollen ihn als
Kanzler mich Scholz seine ersten 100
Tage im Amt dann bewältigt das haben wir
in diesem Video hier beleuchtet aber wie
geht's danach weiter zu Beginn des
Ukraine Kriegs hat Olaf Scholz das
Vertrauen der Wählerinnen und Wähler
immer noch aber schon kurz nach seiner
legendären Erklärung zur Zeitenwende im
März 2022 fallen seine Sympathiewerte
auf einen persönlichen dienstwert im
April 2023 von 0,2 verliert Olaf Scholz
das Vertrauen der Wähler Andrea Wolf von
der Forschungsgruppe Wahlen sagt dazu
also stimmt der Trend geht ganz klar
nach unten allerdings ist es nicht nur
bei ihm der Fall sondern generell ist es
Niveau der Bewertung der zehn
wichtigsten Politiker in im letzten Jahr
nach unten gegangen aber ich würde nicht
sagen dass es zu einem Vertrauensverlust
führt für Olaf Scholz denn auch bei der
Frage wie er seine Arbeit als
Bundeskanzler macht haben wir ja immer
noch Mehrheiten die sagen der macht
seinen Job gut das heißt da gibt's schon
hin und wieder auch Ungeduld und Missmut
und dann geht die Kurve nach unten aber
ein genereller Vertrauensverlust den
würde ich jetzt nicht sehen Miss Mut
äußern die Befragten vor allem bei einem
Punkt z.B geben 66 % im März an sie
vermissen Führungsstärke beim Kanzler
offenbar setzt er sich zu selten durch
wann immer er ein Machtwort spricht
wirklich das allerdings positiv auf
Scholz ansehen aus etwa im Oktober als
er nach einem langen Ampel Streit die
Laufzeit der letzten Atomkraftwerke bis
ins Frühjahr verlängert 36% befürworten
Scholz Handeln 55 Moment wünschen sich
sogar eine Laufzeitverlängerung über den
April hinaus setzt sich der Kanzler in
der Ampel also zu selten durch müsste er
viel öfter den gelben und grünen die
rote Karte zeigen was für ein Wortspiel
im März 2023 kommt der ampelstreit zum
Höhepunkt grüne Klimapolitik und
heizkonzepte gegen gelbe
autobahnausbauten und
Steuererleichterungen dazwischen
ungerührt der Kanzler an dem wieder
alles abzuprallen scheint als hätte er
damit nichts zu tun ganz grundsätzlich
meinen 61% der Befragten im
Politbarometer im April 2023 oder Scholz
setze sich eher nicht durch zuletzt sind
nur noch 46% der Befragten mit der
Arbeit der Regierung zufrieden sowohl
bei Scholz als auch bei seinen beiden
Stellvertretern wirkt sich das negativ
auf die Sympathiewerte aus fast
dreiviertel der Befragten hält Olaf
Scholz außerdem für zu zögerlich gerade
in Bezug auf die Ukraine wünschen sich
die Wählerinnen und Wähler mehr
Tatendrang schon vor einem Jahr hätten
mehr als die Hälfte der Befragten das
politbarometers 56%, die Lieferung
schwerer Waffen unterstützt das kannst
du Scholz erst im Januar grünes Licht
für die Leopard 2 Panzer gegeben hat das
hat vielen Menschen einfach zu lange
gedauert aber trotzdem denke ich muss
wenn diese Entscheidung so getroffen
werden müssen natürlich ganz viele
Aspekte mit berücksichtigt werden die
die ein befragter bei der Beantwortung
dieser Frage natürlich nicht alle im
Kopf haben kann manchmal wünschte man
sich halt dass diese Entscheidung
vielleicht auch der Entscheidungsprozess
besser erklärt wird das ist sicher keine
Stärke von Olaf Scholz dass er die
Menschen mitnimmt bei seiner
Entscheidung so ist seine Art also ich
denke das
das ist etwas was man halt einfach
akzeptieren und ein Stück weit ist es
halt dann auch authentisch
aussetzen und aushalten irgendwie kommt
uns dieser Führungsstil doch bekannt vor
oder experten vermuten das oder scheut
sich von seiner Taktik einen ähnlich
langwierigen Erfolg verspricht die ihm
seine Vorgängerin Angela Merkel von der
CDU hatte aber auf den ersten Blick
scheint Angela Merkel beliebter gewesen
zu sein als oder Scholz ihr Wert lag
durchschnittlich bei 1,8 seiner nur 1,1
Tendenz weiter sinken laut Andrea Wolf
zählt aber nicht nur dass ein Kanzler
beliebt ist sondern bei wem er beliebt
ist was beide eins ist was ich anfangs
auch schon mal angesprochen hatte dass
sie auch von den Anhängern alle anderen
mit Ausnahme der afd-anhänger also bei
den Anhängern der anderen Parteien eben
auch positive Werte kommen also auch da
wertschätzen erfahren und ich glaube das
ist noch entscheidender als an der
Spitze der Top Ten zu stehen dass man
nicht polarisiert sondern dass man
positiv wirkt auch
in einer breiteren Schicht denn das ist
ja dann auch die Aufgabe des
Bundeskanzlers er muss ja dann regieren
für alle und das ist eigentlich das
Wichtigste dass ich sehe bei diesem
Beliebtheitswerten reichen Olaf Scholz
Sympathiewerte aus um Ihnen das
Kanzleramt auch weiter zu sichern seine
Teflonschicht hat ihn in der
Vergangenheit ja immer mal wieder
gerettet aber eventuell könnte diese
Schicht jetzt bröckeln denn die Union
zieht das schärfste Schwert dass die
Opposition hat sie hat einen
Untersuchungsausschuss im Bundestag
beantragt März der CDU-Chef und seine
Mitstreiter möchten beweisen dass Olaf
Scholz als damaliger Oberbürgermeister
Hamburgs im ex-skandal politisch
Einfluss genommen hat auf
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter in der
Finanzverwaltung oder auf Entscheidungen
wir können gespannt sein wie sich der
Kanzler da durch Holz um es mal mit
diesem Wort zu sagen was meint ihr dann
wird Olaf Scholz mit seiner Art ähnlich
erfolgreich wie Angela Merkel oder
schreckt euch das eher ab schreibt gerne
unten in die Kommentare und hier neben
mir findet ihr noch zwei weitere Videos
von dem Kanal da und da gerne klicken
ich sage danke fürs zuschauen und bis
zum nächsten Mal